- [Narrator] Forty miles
southwest of Tucson
between Arizona's Coyote
and Baboquivari mountains
is an old west ranch town like no other.
Cowtown Keeylocko was built
by this man, Ed Keeylocko.
- [Ed Keeylocko] That's
Edward J.B. Keeylocko.
- [Narrator] All with his bare hands.
- [Ed Keeylocko] That's right.
- [Narrator] Like any old
west town, Cowtown Keeylocko
has a church, a bank, a
cemetery and a saloon.
But unlike most other old
west towns, this Cowtown
is still standing, all
because of this man.
- I drink to that.
I've built everything
here, everything you see
round here was done with a small truck.
I had no machinery, but I
figured out how to do it.
Even that water tower, that one there,
hauled that up with a pickup truck.
- [Narrator] Why exactly did Edward
J.B. Keeylocko build his own town?
Ed, born to a black
mother and a white father,
was orphaned at a young
age in Jim Crow America.
- My childhood was rough.
I was light-skinned,
red hair, green eyes.
I can remember a young
kid climbed a tree once, he told me,
“Ed, look up here, I’m up here,”
and he urinated in my face.
And those are the kind of
things that you'd have to
live with, cause you, if you look like me.
- [Narrator] From these
hardships, Keeylocko developed
his independent frontier
spirit, wouldn’t you say so, Ed?
- I'd paddle on my own
canoe, like they say in the West,
I sat on my own broncs,
I rode it out, I’ve done all of this.
- [Narrator] With this lesson in mind,
Ed constructed an old west utopia.
Four decades later, Cowtown continues
its celebration of individuality
with the biannual event
known as Keeylocko Days.
- [Ed Keeylocko] People like
to come to Cowtown Keeylocko.
There's no hatred here, no racism;
we accept you who you are.
You can dream the things that
never were and say why not?
That's the way I, in my mind, thinks.
Lot of people thought I was crazy.
I suppose maybe I am.
Maybe I am, maybe I am.